there is a strange law of psychology
that reveals that small children who
were treated badly by their parents will
always rather oddly blame themselves and
not their parents for their injuries
they hate who they are rather than
hating those who've done them wrong
small children immediately notice when
they're not loved as much as they might
and need to be they understand nothing
of the reasons for this hard-heartedness
but they feel all of the pain and yet
they need to locate some kind of
explanation nevertheless and so they
quickly and intuitively settle on one
that almost always feels most compelling
to them that they have done something
wrong why is Mummy so agitated because
they've done something wrong why is
Daddy so cold because they've done
something wrong why aren't they being
treated kindly because they've done
something wrong why is their little
sister being preferred to them because
they've done something wrong
after a little while of this their whole
character becomes oriented towards guilt
they are in numberless ways simply and
primordially bad
in adult life it then takes very little
to reignite a feeling that somewhere
along the line they have said and done
something awful what precise offense
they believe themselves to have
committed shifts according to events in
their lives and the prevailing public
mood in a religious age they may feel
they've done something wrong in the eyes
of God in an age obsessed with
pedophilia they will feel they've done
harm to a child when racism is being
highlighted as a leading public sin they
might be tortured that they Harbor
racist feelings
closer to whom they will fear that
they've upset their partner hurt their
friends or offended an employee
whenever they make a new friend they
know that soon enough the friend will
realize that they are bad and let them
go
what makes the guild so hard to shake
off is that they can't exactly pinpoint
its origin
fuse mood hangs over them whose title is
simply I have done something wrong
the mood is particularly prone to
descend when they are lonely guilt
thrives on isolation just as it's love
that may disperse it
when this sort of mood reaches a pitch
the sufferer May fantasize about going
to a police station and handing
themselves in there could be such relief
in finally being able to tell the
officials I'm awful I'm guilty one could
be put in handcuffs and led to the cells
and there finally gain some relief from
the awful tension
needless to say there will be no such
benefit in reality the only way to cure
this kind of guilt is to unpick its
Origins that is to realize that we are
of course not bad at all rather that we
have been bullied without Justice into
thinking we might be so we need at last
to exchange self-flagellation for a
little bit of righteous anger against
those who have done us wrong